bagarre
mais l'intérieur mobilisé préfet
l'accusation roland dumas contre-attaqué
demande à comparaître dans l'arène
manifestent demain contre le manque
d'effectifs et de moyens médecin
des n'importe quel projet d'aménagement
et de restes humains
voilà monsieur bonsoir la violence d'un
certain nombre de jeunes devient
inquiétante au point qu'aujourd'hui le
ministre de l'intérieur a appelé tous
les préfets à se mobiliser pour contenir
et réduire un état de fait intolérable
at il dit il faut dire qu'en l'espace de
quelques jours on est passé de la
violence devenue quotidienne incendies
de voitures pillages de magasins
affrontements avec les forces de l'ordre
au meurtre mercredi dernier je vous
rappelle une épicière de la région
d'oron était abattu d'une balle en
pleine tête par garçon de 15 ans à peine
et ce matin au beau milieu du centre
commercial d'evry dans l'essonne au
cours d'un affrontement entre deux
bandes rivales
c'est un adolescent de 17 ans qui a été
abattu d'une balle dans la nuque le
meurtrier âgé lui de 22 ans a été
aussitôt arrêté au domicile de ses
parents
reportage matuchet prélève les larmes
d'une mère le silence d'un père ses
parents kurde viennent d'apprendre la
mort de leur fils et zidane 17 ans
décédée peu après son admission à
l'hôpital d'evry l'adolescent a été tué
et six dans ce centre commercial d'une
balle dans la nuque
l' arme un fusil à canon scié peu
témoins il était 9 heures du matin
la toupie sous le coup là
autour de manifester qui au couple
aurait une quinzaine d'adolescents
je pense qu'ils se sont rencontrés ces
deux rencontres fortuites tout ce que la
loi est un lieu de passage pour deux ans
et demi environ
zidane était de corbeil-essonnes son
agresseur et lui févry âgé de 22 ans il
a reconnu les faits peu après son
arrestation et vieillit corbeille de
citer séparer de quelques kilomètres
s'agit-il d'une vengeance suite à un
racket ou d'un règlement de comptes
entre bandes rivales
ce policier du raid travail dans les
banlieues il connaissait la victime
je crois que ce n'est pas mis
particulièrement motivé c'est arrivé
n'était pas particulièrement violents
aux autres les formations je peux avoir
non c'est un garçon qui bouge et d'un
quartier cet après midi à corbeil un
conseil municipal de prévention de la
délinquance est réuni en urgence
éducateurs policiers ou élus ils ont
lancé un appel au calme
pour sa part la prédispose à lille avant
l'ouverture
nous avons à donner à chacun des acteurs
les informations qu'ils pouvaient donner
contenu de l'entente en cours et
apprendre l'autonomie de nous tenir au
courant régulièrement informés pour
éviter que la rumeur comme qu'on soit
dans cette ville me fasse mon esprit il
a voté sa d'autres drames
un important dispositif policier a été
mis en place ce soir pour éviter des
débordements et réactions de violence
force est de constater entre autres
qu'il y à beaucoup trop d'armes en
circulation en france en 1995
souvenez-vous le gouvernement de
l'époque avait dessiné leur recensement
assortie de mesures contraignantes
et puis aujourd'hui encore l'assemblée
nationale va être saisie d'un projet de
loi sur le contrôle des armes qu'on
partage facebook il ya alliage 15
millions d'armes à feu sans compter
quelques 3 millions de fusils de chasse
ce sont les estimations les cris sérieux
quant au nombre d'armes privé qu'ils
sont fils aujourd'hui en france
des chiffres inquiétants d'autant qu'on
annonce doubler les conflits qui comme à
evry tourner au drame à cause de la
présence d'une arme à feu
pourtant depuis mai 1995 le port et
l'utilisation des armes sont en théorie
soumis à une dégustation plus strictes à
l'époque tous détenteurs d'armes à feu
étaient sommés de la déclarer en
préfecture au commissariat il rester
sinon une amende de 10000 francs et la
confiscation de larmes
un décret qui n'a sans doute pas été
suivies d'effets ce que le ministre de
l'intérieur reconnaît d'ailleurs
ouvertement la gestion passive
j'aimerais que
l'an dernier l'un de nos voisins la
grande bretagne s'est dotée de la
législation sur les armes la plus sévère
au monde
40000 anglais se sont vus retirer leurs
armes de poing en échange d'une
indemnisation de plus d'un milliard de
francs un an plus tôt à dunblane écosse
celles d'enfants avaient été massacrés
par un homme qui se disait amateur
d'armes à feu dans la commune de ben ali
près le roi ans et est aujourd'hui la
rentrée des classes au collège dont
trois élèves sont actuellement en prison
pour le meurtre d'une épicière de 60 ans
tué d'une balle dans la tête
le principal du collège avait décidé
tout simplement parlé ce matin avec les
élèves avant la reprise des cours
reportage vincent nguyen gens rencontrés
juste avant les vacances
deux des agresseurs de l'épicière était
encore en 4e ici le troisième l'auteur
du coup de feu mortel avait récemment
été ré orienter vers un autre
établissement
cinq jours après le drame la rentrée du
collège val saint denis ne pouvait
effectuer comme si de rien n'était et
j'en connaissais et puis on n'est pas
capable de faire ça voilà et puis j'ai
trop connu je pense que c'est parce que
beaucoup d'élèves avaient des choses à
dire
après une minute de silence la première
heure de cours a été consacrée à la
discussion
un exutoire particulièrement émouvant
dans la classe d'alexandre et grégory
lui beaucoup d'enfants pleurer d'émotion
n'ont pas pu parler
cette émission montre bien je pense que
c'est l'espoir de la société que des
enfants ne sont pas insensibles
après cet échange les enseignants ont
insisté sur le non à la violence sur
lisez les réparabilité du mup commune
sous le caractère irréversible du coût
de la vie des enfants qui ont qui sont
qui ont commis cet acte et surtout
insisté sur la partie qui est la plus
importante la distinction qu'il faut
faire entre le réel et les ducs tueur
réel virtuel la frontière était bien
floues -les ce mercredi dans la tête des
adolescents c'est en tout cas la
conviction de leur avocat qui évoque
l'émulation du groupe la violence des
films et c'est entre actis paint ball
comme il l'appelle avec lesquels il
avait l'habitude de jouer j'ai des
enfants qui reproduit au travers de
quelque chose qui a un côté ludique
c'est incontestable un schéma de vie
ça n'est pas la réalité c'est la
virtualité le paintball sans hélas l
image parfaite ce 357 magnum lui est
bien réel
tout comme la décision du parquet les
trois jeunes sont inculpés de tentative
de vol à main armée et d'homicide
volontaire il n'y a toujours pas
officiellement du moins d'affaires
roland dumas même si celui ci
apparaissent sur le devant de la scène
dans une affaire de pots de vin à
l'occasion d'une vente de matériels
militaires à taiwan dans les années
quatre-vingt douze en revanche il ya ce
soir une nouvelle affaire loïk le floch
prigent
l'ancien pdg d'elf ayant été mis en
examen ce soir et laissé en liberté par
les juges chargés du dossier
la société n qui dirigeait à l'époque
ayant employé madame deviers joncour qui
elle est bel et bien au centre de la
sphère reportage neely caroff et
christopher hill 2 11 loïk le floch
prigent était déjà sous le coup de dix
mises en examen dans l'affairé elf
celle d'aujourd'hui pour abus de biens
sociaux visent l'extrême générosité de
l'entreprise qu'il dirigeait à l'égard
de christine deviers joncour sur les
comptes de cet ami de roland dumas les
juges jolie et vichnievsky ont trouvé
près de 70 millions de francs versés par
le groupe elf
l'essentiel proviendrait selon christine
deviers-joncour d'une commission versée
pour faire approuver par l'ancien
ministre des affaires étrangères il
vente de frégates à taïwan mais selon
elle la mission était cheveux une
version confirmée par roland dumas lui
même dans un entretien au figaro il se
dit il dit se rappeler de l'insistance
de son ami embauché chez elf sans son
aide
lorsqu'elle lui a parlé des frégates il
a le souvenir de la voirie conduite de
son bureau
les souvenirs se font moins précis sur
l'origine des nombreux versements en
espèces constatées sur son compte en
banque
roland dumas il évoque notamment les
activités de son cabinet d'avocat et la
vente d'oeuvres d'art
il a même commandé un audit mais il est
catégorique il n'a perçu aucun centime
par une loi ou une autre issue des
commissions de la sphère de brega les
commissions qui selon lui ne concernait
pas le ministère des affaires étrangères
seul l'elysée le ministère des finances
pourrait autoriser de tels versements
sur les dossiers de van damme mais il
révèle que les frégates aurait fait
l'objet d'une commission bien plus
important c'était de l'ordre de deux
milliards et demi de francs environ
les noms des bénéficiaires qui ne lui
appartient pas de dévoiler son mentionné
dans un docu mais ce document comme la
plupart nail archives diplomatiques
qu'il se propose de remettre pourrait
être couvert par le secret défense
si les juges d'instruction accepté ces
pièces elle prendrait le risque d'être
dessaisi du dossier au profit de la cour
de justice
roland dumas qui n'a toujours pas
l'intention de démissionner de la
présidence du conseil constitutionnel
demande donc vous l'avez entendu à être
jugé par ses pairs en quelques sortes à
savoir la cour de justice de la
république une instance réservé aux
membres du gouvernement notamment en
exercice au moment des faits qui leur
sont reprochés à nizar mieux fidéliser
roland dumas tient depuis longtemps à ce
que la cour de justice de la république
soit 6 parce que les investigations en
cours concerne ses activités 2000 se
répondent ses défenseurs et que les deux
juges ne sont donc pas compétent
la conduite est en effet le tribunal des
ministres et anciens ministres mais
c'est aussi un autre style d'instruction
eva joly et laurence crise qui sont
réputés très réfléchie elle n'hésite pas
à mettre en détention
la livre blanc du mayet depuis plusieurs
mois la cour de justice elle en cinq ans
d'activité n'a jamais placé personne en
prison
les auditions ils sont polis les
questions donner un peu à la vente sur
les trois dossiers qu'elle à celui dont
le 120 amis n'ai eu aucun des ministres
concernés non comparons devant elle mais
pour son ancien président la cour de
justice travaille discrètement mais sans
complaisance la côte justice à
l'instruit comme toutes les juridictions
et serait-elle question de gérer une
affaire cela n'a aucun sens cela
n'existe pas seuls des plaignants mais
il n'y en a pas contre roland dumas le
procureur général ou la chambre
d'accusation peuvent saisir la cour de
justice
mais pour l'instant la condition du
parquet est clair il est trop tôt pour
une saisie officiellement la sphère
d'humaniste par les deux juges qui ont
convoqué l'ancien ministre sur le 18
mars prochain sont prêtes à le mettre en
examen
si la colo justice est saisie elles
devront alors transmettre et ne plus
toucher à ce volet de l'affairé
dernier élément de cette affaire pour
aujourd'hui isabelle guillou au ministre
de la justice a estimé que la
présomption d'innocence en faveur de
roland dumas n'avait pas été respectée
le président du conseil continuez c'est
constitutionnel pardon n'étant pas pour
l'instant ni mis en examen ni même
témoin dans cette affaire est admis que
la présomption d'innocence n'est pas
toujours respecté la parité des
scolaires alors qu'il faut faire en
sorte qu'elles soient davantage un
problème de principe d'une façon
générale quand on traite des témoins
comme s'il était coupable je vous
rappelle que même quand on est mis en
examen on est présumé innocent c'est ça
qu'il faut rappeler je prends chaque
fois maintenant il faut que
l'information soit là on n'a pas de
raison le cacher l'information n'a pas
de raison non plus et qu il faut que la
justice fasse ce qu'elle a appris au
rythme qu'elle pense de voir le bordeaux
procès de maurice papon on aborde la
dernière ligne droite celle des
plaidoiries en commençant par les
parties civiles le premier à s'exprimer
maître boulanger a résumé à sa façon
cinq mois de débats pour lui la cuisine
est un jeune mâle faisant je le cite qui
s'est mué en un milliard obstiné
dominique verdeilhan sur place depuis 17
ans gérard boulanger tient le dossier
papon à bout de bras 17 ans qu'il
prépare sa plaidoirie résultat plus de
six heures de monologue esquisse d'un
portrait d'abord papon ou le jeune homme
malfaisants qui s'est mué en deuil à
obstiné l'avocat condamne le crime
collectif de toute une préfecture
incline de bureau mais aussi selon
maître boulanger un crime de terriers
rice ils ont chassé les juifs pas par
plaisir sans plaisir et lui ont fait
parce que c'était leur travail et c'est
ça qui pose le problème moral le plus
redoutable
rim aussi contre la mémoire car pour
maître boulanger maurice papon a essayé
de reconstruire son passé en se targuant
d'appartenir à la résistance sachez
dira-t-il aux jurés qu'en condamnant
maurice papon ou ne condamnerait pas
résistants alors que les jurés attentif
depuis cinq mois semble avoir abandonné
leur stylo maurice papon est le seul
aujourd'hui à prendre des notes car
avant le délibéré dans une quinzaine de
jours
il a l'intention de répondre point par
point aux 26 avocats des parties civiles
qui vont se succéder pendant une semaine
trois cent mille francs pour diffamation
et un million de francs de dommages et
intérêts attribués à françois léotard
qui avait porté plainte contre les deux
journalistes qu'il avait indirectement
accusé dans un livre du meurtre du
député du var yann piat
les condamnés ont décidé de faire appel
catherine mégret maire front national de
vitrolles condamné à trois mois de
prison avec sursis pour complicité de
provocation à la haine raciale pour ses
propos sur les immigrés publié dans un
quotidien allemand en revanche la
demande d'inéligibilité n'a pas été
suivi par et dans l'île de la réunion le
volcan du piton de la fournaise est
entré cet après-midi en éruption après
six années d'inactivité a priori
l'éruption illimité ne présente aucun
danger pour les populations alentour
stéphane lehr majestueux le spectacle du
piton de la fournaise du livre ses
entrailles
aux yeux de tous les premières l'avons
surgi aux alentours de 15 heures heure
locale
s'échappant par plusieurs fissures dans
le court central du volcan une lave très
fluide qui limite donc les risques
d'explosion du cratère
sur l'acompte nord-est plusieurs coups
les zèbres la montagne elles se dirigent
vers la mer
en suivant la trace d'une précédente
éruption pour l'instant sans aucun
risque pour la population dans la
réunion il ya un rempart naturel qui est
fait par cette loupe de glissements ici
qui a laissé un gigantesque mur qui
confine un les coulées de lave à
l'intérieur de cette espèce
d'amphithéâtre donc les l'afp à partir
de là on calme au regard de s'écouler
vers la mer dans cette direction là
hélas la carte le montre très bien il
n'y a quasiment pas d'habitation seule
petite crainte qu'une feuille
supplémentaire secret cette fois en
dehors de l'enclos mais cela est arrivé
que deux fois dans l'histoire récente du
volcan depuis qu'il est observé le piton
de la fournaise cool en moyenne une fois
tous les trois ans mais la dernière
éruption remonte à 1992 beaucoup de
magma a donc pu s'accumuler ce qui fait
craindre aux observateurs que la
fournaise met du temps à s'endormir
les incendies qui s'étaient déclarés
dans l'arrière pays niçois samedi et
dimanche ont été maîtrisés ce matin 220
hectares ont été ravagés dans les
vallées de la roya y de l'estéron les
pompiers restent en alerte que même sur
place en attendant une reprise
éventuelle des cracks du cuistre au
moment où vous remplissez sans aucun
doute aux déclarations de revenus une
information qui va sans doute vous
intéresser les moyens informatiques dont
dispose désormais elle est servie des
impôts ronde plus en plus difficile
toute tentative de tricherie
surtout pour les salariés dans la mesure
où un certain nombre de fichiers sont
recoupées ce qui laisse peu de
possibilité de passer au travers des
mailles des filets reportage arnaud
étaient terribles événements jusqu'au 30
mars
l'heure est au calcul mais gare aux
erreurs chaque déclaration fera l'objet
d'une vérification
les agents du fisc early show ligne
après ligne en cas de problème
la sanction une notification de
redressement autrement dit un contrôle
fiscal
les montant des redressements explose
220 pour son augmentation en 12 l'an
passé ils ont rapporté à l'état
74 milliards de francs le tiers provient
de particuliers chaque année moins
nombreux à échapper aux mailles du filet
on utilise aujourd'hui des procédures de
rapprochement informatique lui permettre
de mieux cibler les contrôles et qui
permettent surtout concentré ses tirs ce
contrôle sur dossier sur des revenus
assez simple comme ceux des salariés par
exemple
globalement il faut retenir c'est que
les salariés ont pratiquement aucune
chance d'échapper sur le terme un
contrôle alors que les entreprises et
certaines catégories de revenus ont
beaucoup plus de chance sur le terme est
choqué mais lorsqu'une entreprise doit
rendre des comptes
le fisc se montrent souvent plus sévères
que par le passé aujourd'hui
l'administration n'hésite pas non plus à
faire des comptes a fait jusqu'au bout
jusqu'au conseil d'état alors qu'avant
il y avait plus de transactions
peut-être été signé plus de négociation
entrée libre
certes les contrôles tissot varie selon
les professions où il existe des recours
contre l'administration plaisent ils
sont longs et coûteux et plus de 80% des
contrôles sur pièces aboutissent ils
concernent les particuliers suivi du
conte doivent payer alors que des sans
papiers occupent toujours la cathédrale
d'evry le ministre de l'intérieur jean
pierre chevènement indiqué aujourd'hui
que la circulaire de régularisation des
sans-papiers de l'été dernier avait
abouti à ce jour à 32000 réponse
positive est à 30 mille demandes
rejetées l'enseignant de perpignan qui
avait fait publier un faux avis de décès
en catalan du nouveau préfet de corse
bernard bonnet a finalement été
simplement condamnée à 1 franc
symbolique de dommages et intérêts le
procureur avait pourtant requis contre
lui une peine de prison avec sursis
jean marie messier pdg de la générale
les eaux a finalement décidé aujourd'hui
d'accélérer le processus de regroupement
avec havas est une fusion pure et simple
qui étaient décidées par les deux
conseils d'administration et le pdg
d'havas pierre dauzier à céder
immédiatement son poste havas continuera
à être le pôle multimédia l'entreprise
mais va changer le nom dans quelques
mois mettant ainsi un terme à 166 années
d'histoire
koba voici charles havas fondateur de la
première agence de presse au monde
c'était en 1832
au début ils se contentent de traduire
les journaux étrangers puis plus tard il
vend ses propres dépêche
charles habas se lance aussi dans la
publicité d'autres diront dans la
propagande officieuse du pouvoir même
jacques séguéla ne résistera pas à la
toute puissance de ce groupe avec lequel
ils se marient en 91 aujourd'hui c'est
havas qui s'incline devant le souris en
patron de la générale des eaux jean
marie messier déjà premier actionnaire à
30%
il vient d'annoncer la fusion des deux
groupes est de placer un de ses protégés
à la tête davasse je ne regarde pas
masquer ma lieux de pouvoir
je regarde havas comme un lieu de
création est ce que nous propose
aujourd'hui arras ce n'est pas la mort
le hamas
c'est une deuxième vie pour pour havas
et les nouvelles vies pour jean marie
messier qui hérite des activités la base
dans cinq grands domaines celui qui le
fascine le plus l'audiovisuel avec
canal+ détenue à 34%
la publicité avec le numéro un français
havas advertising l'affichage l'édition
et enfin les voyages les loisirs la
générale des eaux apporte de son côté le
domaine de la téléphonie avec cegetel et
sfr
jean marie messier paris sur la mise en
commun des différents fichiers d'abonnés
un nouveau géant qui portera un nouveau
nom dès l'approbation du projet par les
actionnaires le 11 mai prochain
l'international
attention si vous devez prendre l'avion
demain soit à roissy ou à orly les une
grève des sapeurs pompiers ce qui va
limiter le nombre de pistes en activité
des retards sont bons qu'à prévoir aussi
bien sur les vols internationaux que sur
les vols intérieurs
l'élection régionale dans notre tour de
france une halte ce soir en franche
comté dans cette région c'est la gauche
qui connaît quelques problèmes l'union
trois ministres du gouvernement jospin
sont présents jean-pierre chevènement
pierre moscovici dominique voynet ce qui
les divise
c'est le tgv et l'opposition qui détient
la préside
du conseil régional espère bien tirer
profit reportage guilaine chenu le
patrick des chemins 15,3 ministre aux
communes des régions les plus discrètes
de france ce soir là à besançon la
gauche célèbre en grande pompe son unité
trois ministres c'est beaucoup surtout
quand ils ne sont pas du même parti mais
qu'il faut choisir un seul candidat pour
la région il a fallu l'intervention de
lionel jospin pour éviter la crise de
nerfs entre le socialiste pierre
moscovici et jean pierre chevènement le
patron du mouvement de citoyens
pour christian poos du mdc s'est réglé
si la gauche gagne il ira s'asseoir dans
le fauteuil de président de région
françois hollande a même promis par
lettre à jean pierre chevènement si la
gauche emportait cinq régions
la franche-comté reviendra en mouvement
des citoyens au nom des équilibres
nationaux partager les postes de
responsabilité et de faire en sorte que
chacun puisse apporter son dynamisme sa
compétence céder la place aux frères
ennemis le mdc la consigne parisienne
n'est pas facile à accepter pour pierre
moscovici
implanté dans la région depuis sept ans
il ne rate pas une occasion sur toutes
les ondes de continuer le bras de fer
avec les ennemis que jean pierre
chevènement seront l'épiné dorsale de
cette majorité
nous aurons la majorité de la majorité
au futur conseil régional nous pèserons
on demande beaucoup aux bars et celle de
ne pas être hégémoniques
ce n'est pas parce que d'autres attaques
ou de déneiger monique château avait une
commande doit donc sans partager
pendant ce temps jean françois humbert
le candidat de la droite fait une
campagne très local quatre ans km et 9
réunions par jour pour tenter de
conserver la région de la pédagogie et
quelques attaques contre ses trois
ministres qui ont du mal à s'entendre
même sur le tracé du futur tgv rhin
rhône pour madame voynet il est élevé
mais fort paris dont monsieur
chevénement à droite comme à gauche on
souhaite que le front national ne
devienne pas l'arbitré de cette élection
si la gauche arrive en tête le sort de
la région se décidera à paris des
médecins scolaires vont manifester
demain défilé contre le manque de moyens
et puis aussi le manque d'effectifs ils
sont actuellement 1800 pour toute la
france ce qui représente statistiquement
un médecin pour 7500 enfants bref
aujourd'hui un enfant est vu à son
entrée dans le circuit primaire et une
fois assez sortie du collège une fois
tous les dix ans
c'est peu d'autant plus qu'aujourd'hui
en raison de la crise économique bon
nombre d'écoliers nous voit deux
médecins que celui de l'école conçoit ce
ballet patrick et les médecins scolaires
elle travaille dans la banlieue de
marseille dans des quartiers réputés
définitive tout son secteur et la dent
ce trousseau de clés 34 établissements
de la maternelle au bac 1600 élèves
tous les jours elle change d'endroit son
rôle vérifier la santé et
l'épanouissement des enfants comme tous
ses confrères elle a fait la faculté de
médecine puis a suivi une formation
spécifique à l'éducation nationale a
rappelé que comme le pastis la visite de
si l'on est obligatoire elle dure 45
minutes si possible avec les parents
pour évaluer les enfants il faut du
temps il faut les comprendre les
connaître mais aujourd'hui comme
beaucoup de médecins scolaires hélène
n'arrive plus à suivre si l'élève façon
systématique je ne savais
c'est dommage on ne les voyons plus que
deux fois le médecin scolaire n'a plus
que deux bilans à faire à l'entrée au cp
et à la sortie de troisième que le
médecin scolaire
il existe en clair pour les vaccinations
indispensable et ce sont ses enfants
qu'elle aimait fait de suivre en plus de
ces visites obligatoires des réunions
avec l'administration de ses
interventions dans les classes pour
faire de la prévention
le problème c'est qu'ils sont le plus en
plus nombreux il faudrait que les
secteurs des effectifs de m
5000 maintenant il faudra compter
pressés à moitié moins c'est un rêve
aussi pour frédéric mainbourg elle
travaille en milieu rural dans le
maine-et-loire son secteur car emprunter
coller du bij n 2 kilomètres les unes
des autres
un problème pour le médecin un problème
aussi pour les élèves de 6ème et ont
suffisamment tôt et tu te couches pour
certains enfants l'école est le seul
contact avec l'extérieur
dans ce département où le taux de
suicide est l'un des plus importants de
france
le médecin n'a pas le temps d'écouter la
détresse des blessés
dit pas les choses non dis donc
valable sur le plan physique mais aussi
sur le plan psychologique donc ça ne va
pas contourner dépressive porte on
souffre mentalement moralement et bien
on n'en parle pas la frustration elle
est issue du fait que bon on est dans le
dépistage c'est un temps mais dont on
nous demandait quand nous dans notre
lettre de mission quand même de suivre
et bien moi je me rends compte que le
suivi est en effet très difficile avec
deux vip en bilan pourtant les médecins
scolaires sont très attachés à leur
mission et entendent conserver leur
activité pour un meilleur suivi
il souhaiterait par exemple pouvoir
ordonner une consultation gratuite
le médecin de ville pourrait alors
prendre le relais et et internationale
la crise du kosovo à londres les pays du
groupe de contact etats unis angleterre
italie allemagne france et russie ont
décidé de nommer un médiateur l'ancien
premier ministre espagnol felipe
gonzalez lamination complétée par une
proposition de résolution des nations
unies décida immédiatement d'un embargo
économique en direction de la serbie le
tout jusqu'à l'ouverture d'un véritable
dialogue entre la serbie et la majorité
albanaise du kosovo seule la russie faut
le dire ne s'est pas associée à cette
décision je place au kosovo nouvelle
manifestation aujourd'hui contre les
autorités serbes
l'orme aussi sous ses vaches blanches
des dizaines de corps ceux des victimes
de l'offensive il ya trois jours les
forces de sécurité serbes dans la région
de brennus à à 25 km à l'ouest de
pristina la principale ville du kosovo
parmi ces corps celui d'adam jazira le
chef de l'armée de libération du kosovo
un homme qualifié de terroriste par les
autorités de belgrade mais héros des
manifestants qui ce matin défilé à
pristina pour demander l'arrêt de la
répression serbe et l'intervention de la
communauté internationale
drapeau américain v de la victoire pour
la première fois depuis de longues
années une manifestation de plus de
20000 personnes à pristina s'est
déroulée dans le calme sans
l'intervention musclée des forces de
l'ordre
une manifestation pour faire pression
sur le groupe de contact européens
russes et américains qui à londres ce
matin discuter d'un plan d'action
destiné à infléchir la politique du
président serbe milosevic au kosovo
suppression des visas pour les
responsables serbes de la répression
sanctions économiques et embargo
international sur les armes entre la
ligne dure voulue par les états unis et
la volonté russe de temporiser c'est
finalement une solution intermédiaire
qui l'a emporté les pressions des
menaces pressions très fortes pour que
les autorités de belgrade change
radicalement d'attitude et de politiques
sur ce quoi il s'agit d'entrer dans une
politique de dialogue pour aboutir à une
autonomie substantielle pour le co ce
gros ce qui est la seule solution viable
des sanctions qui n'entreront de toute
façon pas en vigueur avant le 25 mars
un délai qui peut paraître long au
moment où l'albanie loin de vouloir
calmer le jeu a placé son armée en état
d' alerte et ses chats le long de sa
frontière avec le kosovo
en algérie le gouvernement a décidé de
changer sa politique de communication
après la guerre sans images comprend des
terroristes islamiques c'est désormais
la télévision algérienne qui propose des
documents relatifs à des opérations de
l'armée algérienne comme celle ci un
groupe de combattants c'est me tuer
après l'assaut donné soit par les airs
et parterres contre une ferme où il
s'était réfugié à leur retour en france
à l'occasion de la journée des femmes
dans le monde
le premier ministre lionel jospin il
hier a demandé à tous les ministères de
recourir aux appellations féminine des
fonctions ne menace pas insistent donc
après madame la ministre
contre l'avis de l'académie française ce
sont toutes les dénominations de titres
de grades qui devront être féministe ni
carzou janvier normandin et on peut les
donner le la aux ministres aux
capitaines ou l'accord haut-commissaire
du sexe féminin telle était la volonté
de lionel jospin est désormais la
décision
actu car au lendemain de la journée des
femmes le bien ministre a pris une
circulaire l'objet est d'imposer la
féminisation des noms de métiers de
grave de type pour commencer au sein du
gouvernement et les institutions de
l'état
ainsi dans l'armée après la suppression
des quotas qui limitait le nombre de
femmes sauf ici la grande muette va
devoir trouver l'équivalent féminin
dégrade et ce à la grande satisfaction
des intéressés le langage mission je
pense aussi que chacun s'impose par ses
compétences par ses qualités et je ne
doute appelée commandante faire quoi que
ce soit de hénon déplaise à l'académie
française du côté des rédacteurs comme
der électrice de dictionnaires cette
évolution du langage et déjà au
programme des prochaines éditions
d'autant plus aisément que la patronne
comme le patron du robert sont l'un
comme l'autre favorable à ce nouvel
usage
je ne vois pas que l'académie n'ai
jamais jamais empêché que l'on dise la
concierge le banc cierges
quand il s'agit de quelque chose qui ne
serait pas dans les règles du français
comme le fait de dire la professeure
l'ingénieur avec 1 au bout pour le fond
et québécois d'ailleurs là je me suis
fait pas très favorable parce que ça
conduit à changer les règles ce qui
n'est jamais très sage brèche pour
généraliser la féminisation il va sans
doute falloir inventer de nouveaux
termes ainsi en ira-t-il pour nos
auteurs sculpteur et peintre du sexe
féminin mais aussi et al'inverse pour
leur mue
lorsque celles ci on à barbe le salon de
l'image virtuelle en trois dimensions
imagina vient de se terminer aujourd'hui
à monaco si l'on fait exception des jeux
la 3d apporte énormément dans un secteur
comme celui de l'architecturé de
l'aménagement de l'environnement
désormais en effet les spécialistes vont
pouvoir visualiser très nettement les
conséquences bien réelles et pas
seulement virtuelles d'un chantier sur
un paysage mais toutes ces images pour
le savoir sont eux mêmes le fruit d'un
travail de fourmi sont maintenant tout
rica
ces plantes poussent fleurissent et
zélie sur commande
une nature créée par la main de l'homme
dans ce laboratoire unique à la pointe
de la technologie
les branches de sapin de chênes érables
c'est l'univers de ces botaniste année
après année il passe au crible des
centaines d'espèces végétales gross
serait temps me des branches nombre de
bourgeons épaisseur et textures de
l'école
aucun détail n'est délaissé des millions
de données immédiatement avalé par
l'ordinateur
un travail de fourmi pour faire passer
la nature dans le monde virtuel
vous avez une 1ère pouces qui a été mise
en général au printemps était secondes
de pouce qui sont émises un peu plus
tard le plus souvent dans la seine jean
c'est une caractéristique du chêne donc
ça séoul et simuler une chaîne et bien
c'est quelque chose qu'il faudra rendre
parce que d'autres espèces ne font pas
du tout ça ne prochaine le revoilà mais
pour des promeneurs du dimanche
impossible de leur co le chaîne
entièrement mis en équation
grâce aux mesures botanique le but
trouver les lois mathématiques gouverne
la nature aux pages et des pages de
calcul pour obtenir cela
des clones informatique voici par
exemple un cerisier tout en lui est issu
du réel la circulation de la sève la
croissance des branches la taille de
l'arbre et même la formation des fleurs
une nature virtuelle que l'on peut
vieillir au rajeunira volonté que l'on
peut faire varier en fonction des
saisons arbres arbustes plantes pour
l'instant 4000 espèces comptes
enregistrés dans ces terres biens
informatiques une banque de données
utilisée désormais pour les programmes
d'aménagement du territoire
maintenant on peut dire que quand on
fait un grand projet d'autoroute bien à
tracer tgv et bien il faut montrer aux
riverains
l'impact paysager qu'il y aura dans sa
totalité
tremblay en france il communes de la
région parisienne grignoter au sud par
l'urbanisation et au nord par
l'extension de l'aéroport de roissy le
maire lui veut préserver 500 hectares
d'espacés verts
une rature verte là aurait pu
s'implanter une zone industrielle pour
appliquer ses amis lycée
des réunions publiques m6 démarre sous
les yeux des habitants la commune de
tremblay est tout à coup des sauts de
puce dans le siècle prochain graphique
l'informatique et à la technologie du
virtuel où les scénarios même les flux
marquent son permis de vingt ans
maintenant en termes de projets on
travaille sur des petites superficies
sont de petits projets des projets
d'architecturé mais rarement sur des
paysages complet sur l'évolution une
d'un morceau de ville et boire d'une
voire d'une ville d'une ville entière et
c'est ce qu'il nous importe nous de
pouvoir montrer à des vents qui ne sont
absolument pas des spécialistes en
quelques secondes une carrière véritable
cicatrices dans un environnement laisse
sa place à un paysage nouveau lorsque
l'activité racistes et une balade
virtuelle dans le temps et l'espace
sultan était possible ou même le rythme
des saisons peut-être 12
une semaine de défilés de mode qui
commence dans le prêt à porter avec la
collection de l'hiver 98-99 ce soir ne
marque prestigieuse vuitton céline qui
toutes les deux ont fait appel à des
stylistes américains pour rajeunir leur
barque d'un côté et s'assurer aussi un
caractère international
nicole cornibert loi mal au dos l'aviez
de présenter sa collection c'est marc
jacobs pour vuitton il est soulagé
déterminer non traite encore dans les
affres de la création c'est michael kors
élégance pur sobre n'êtes pas du bis pas
d'accessoires de maquillage pas question
de détourner l'attention de la
perfection de la ligne de la précision
des finitions et l'association marc
jacobs louis vuitton
j'essaie de garder le style vuitton dans
cette première collection romantique et
battre autant que fort de garder un
équilibre prescrire ici les pieds à la
tête
l'enjeu économique est énorme pas de
place pour l'erreur
notre approche des artisans maroquiniers
ou malquier et et son approche du droit
d'apporter super de matériaux d et
univers du luxe n'est pas d'accord non
c'est la discrétion assurée et c'est
gagné pour les ré je suis vraiment
heureux épuisé mais maintenant je peux
rentrer à new york et préparer mes
propres collections
c'est probablement ce qu'elle n'aurait
fait qu'un confrère et néanmoins ami
michael kors
mais il doit présenter sa collection
pour celine samedi il porte dans les
accessoires à l'aide de photos il
organise l'ordre du défilé quelquefois
voulais mélanger les choses et vous
devez les porter différemment pour le
travail le porter la même veste et
j'aurais plus peur
il aime travailler les étapes généreuse
et confortable la fourrure le propos
d'îles et les cachemires double face ils
sont légers luxe à prix doux les
réinventer un souffle jeunes venus
d'ailleurs pour six jours avant de
quitter le rappel des principaux titres
de l'actualité
face aux accusations la république ni
juge en charge du dossier ont mis ce
soir en examen l'ancien de tf1 et nimani
de coeur parfois aller